Позиція внутрішньої відповідальності,
яка в цьому відрізку життя в мене з'явилася,
за те, що є навколо мене,
власна, автоматична й дуже природна,
зробила Франківськ моїм фокусом уваги і роботи.
Мені здається, що тут важливо,
щоб Франківськ був містом,
в якому вільно рухається енергія створення.
Тобто в якому люди хочуть винаходити,
перевинаходити нові моделі,
в якому люди відкриті до взаємодії,
і в якому люди відповідально ставляться до середовища,
в якому вони функціонують.
Ну от, власне, це і є наш «Промприлад».
Тобто це прохідна історична. Завод був величезний.
Ми, власне, взялися за ревіталізацію лише тої частини,
яка від нього залишилася, — два гектари землі.
Тут загально 28 тисяч квадратних метрів приміщень.
Тут, при виході, ви можете побачити таблички з іменами,
назвами компаній-партнерів, інвесторів
і різних міжнародних наших партнерів,
які нас підтримують грантами.
Ми побачили потенціял у таких закинутих
постіндустріальних зон,
які є частиною проблем для сучасних міст.
Але треба було знати формулу, як до них зайти.
І, відповідно, ми почали вивчати,
які моделі існують у світі.
Наш проєкт належить до такої нової сфери
як імпакт-інвестування.
У світі цьому напряму від сили
менш ніж десять років насправді.
А в пострадянському просторі
ми є абсолютними піонерами.
Особливо в такому масштабі.
Тобто це є бізнес, але який слугує вирішенню
якихось важливих, комплексних суспільних задач.
Але разом з тим він є прибутковим для своїх інвесторів.
Ну ось ми на «Промприладі».
Прогуляймось і я покажу, що тут у нас є.
Multimedia lab — це і освітній проєкт,
і студія продакшену.
Вони займаються розвитком професій навколо медіа.
Це аудіо, фото, відео, анімація, доповнена реальність.
Фактично це є і коворкінг, і освітні програми,
і студія, де можна виготовляти різний продукт, пов'язаний з медіа.
Взагалі я навчався на електрика,
потім працював контролером.
Я жив у селі і, наприклад, коли малим дивився фільми,
це ще був чорно-білий телевізор.
Мені завжди було цікаво,
як роблять спецефекти, як усе знімають.
Наталя зараз веде три проєкти на «Промприладі».
Один з них — «Дрібнота».
Це проєкт неформальної освіти для дітей.
Другий проєкт — це Shuflia.
Це виробництво виробів зі шкіри.
Але найважливіший зараз проєкт — це бренд Framiore.
Це екоодяг, який розробляють для глобальних ринків.
Тут, на «Промприладі», зараз вони закінчують будувати
«R&D центр» тестування цього одягу повного циклу.
Ми зараз в процесі завершення вже всіх ремонтних робіт.
Хлопці зараз заміряють і будуть нам
встановлювати кондиціонування і тепло.
Наступного тижня ми вішатимемо лампи
і в кінці наступного тижня плануємо переїзд.
Тут буде швейний цех.
Такий бек-офіс, переговорка.
Ми — бренд світу,
і ми б хотіли розповідати про різні народи.
Ми не хочемо зациклюватися на тому,
що є в нас всередині.
Ось такі деталі. Ще є валяні пальто, сумки.
Це виготовляють в Косові по уйгурських мотивах.
Ми досліджуємо патерни і малюнки.
Такий зв'язок з українськими майстрами.
На сьогодні у нас є 510 співінвесторів.
Щодня приєднуються нові.
Ми кілька місяців тому відкрили
другий інвестиційний раунд.
Перший успішно закрили в кінці минулого року.
Залучили перших п’ять мільйонів доларів.
І зараз активно залучаємо наступні ресурси
вже на наступні стадії будівництва і реконструкції корпусів.
Поєднавши тенденції світові
й наші напрацювання, через власний досвід,
так поступово ми викристалізували цю модель.
І вона вже показує, що має право на життя.
Ба більше, вона викликає інтерес в інших міст та країн.
Fin Impact і лідерка цього проєкту Галина Грибна,
з якою ми дуже багато років співпрацювали
в межах і «Теплого міста», і «Промприладу».
Галя створила зараз проєкт з підтримки малого,
середнього і великого бізнесу.
Так народжуються вже нові компанії
завдяки «Промприладу» і на «Промприладі».
Ми — фінансова компанія, яка, здавалося б,
не має нічого дотичного до мистецтва,
Але я завжди кажу, що фінанси — це про креатив.
Тому ми маємо такий спільний проєкт з художниками.
Ми надаємо свій простір в користування для того,
щоб вони могли експонувати свої роботи.
Це річка. Річка тече в Яремче.
От тече, ніби зрозуміло. Пейзаж.
Мистецький цех, в якому працює
Ярема Стецик і Віталій Грех,
це простір, в якому вони творять
і свої продукти (комерційні і мистецькі),
і простір, в якому відбуваються
різні мистецькі події, мистецькі навчання.
Мене звати Ярема. Це дружина Наталя.
А це мій кум Юра.
Комерційна складова цієї майстерні
— це інтер'єрні штуковини.
Це ми робимо побілки.
Робимо такі, які вміємо.
Їх вигадуємо, експериментуємо.
Відкрили школу з побілок.
Це така складова,
яка дозволяє говорити з людьми на інші теми.
Про побілку люди говорять частіше, ніж про мистецтво.
З ними можна починати розмови
про побілку і закінчити мистецтвом.
Я взагалі пейзажист. Коли стараєшся малювати пейзаж
навіть якимось найгіршим способом,
то все одно він виходить
крізь якусь призму дизайну, знань.
Ну видно, що якісь гори.
Батько тут працював у 1970-х роках.
Він тут керував бюром естетики. Він теж художник.
Зробив велику роботу на фасаді.
Взагалі, інвестором «Промприладу» може стати кожен.
Це як люди, так і організації, чи бізнеси.
Але в нас є етичний фільтр.
Нам дуже важливо, щоб люди і компанії,
які до нас приєднуються,
розуміли, що доєднуються
до важливих перетворень в районі і в країні.
Також важливо, щоб вони ціннісно з нами співпадали.
Щоб ті капітали, які заходять в проєкт,
були прозорими, відкритими.
Бо кожен, хто приєднується,
стає частиною спільноти «Промприладу».
Тож це такий природний фільтр.
Не кожен зрозуміє, про що це.
І так можна підсвітити таких людей, подібних собі,
з якими можна говорити і продумувати наступні проєкти.
Це, безумовно, один із найважливіших
і приємних компонентів цього проєкту.
Первинні завдання — це допомогти місту
і регіону перейти на нову якість.
Фактично перезапусти свої основні системи і
допомогти місту перейти в кардинально нову якість.
З пострадянських контекстів у сучасний розвиток.
Мені подобається двір «Промприладу» тим,
що попри всі забудови навколо, тут є своя атмосфера.
В принципі, це все лишається за кадром.
Завдяки власним будівлям і деревам
тут відчувається своя атмосфера.
Коли ми сюди запустимо життя,
бо зараз поки що територія закрита,
з наступного року ми її повністю відкриваємо
і робимо доступною цілодобово.
Тобто тут реально почнеться справжнє життя.
Це цех, який буде перетворений
на найбільший майданчик для подій у місті.
Ось такий він фантастичний.
Він фантастичний за своїм розміром і об'ємом.
Ось тут частина приміщення буде розділена на дві зали,
де можна буде проводити конференції, концерти, вечірки.
А ось цю частину ангару ми мінімально відчищаємо
і тут можна буде проводити різні виставки,
знову ж таки концерти більшого масштабу.
Загалом ця інфраструктура зможе приймати
одночасно події до 3-4 тисяч людей.
Разом з двором.
Ось просто вигляд зверху самого заводу,
видно весь масштаб.
Поступово за наступні три роки весь цей масштаб
має бути повністю реалізований.
Тут буде ще один поверх, добудований сучасно.
І з кінця буде частина готелю в ньому,
потім перехід в ресторан.
Потім перехід у фудхаб.
Це буде кітчен-коворкінг.
Тобто тут розроблятимуть нові кулінарні продукти,
фуд, фудтех тощо.
І закінчуватись буде Urban Garden.
О, морква, клас!
Смачна!
Ну ми вже знаємо, що морква тут
краще росте на «Промприладі».
У центральній частині... Як кажуть, що на східній
частині України те росте краще, на західній інше.
У центральній частині міста морква росте добре.
Улітку це є міський сад на даху.
Шість квадратних метрів, які згодом зростуть в сто разів
і перенесуться на цей дах.
Це цікаво, незвично і дає можливість залучати людей.
У нас мета не виростити, а показати цінність цього.
Що можна робити це в домашніх умовах,
що можна робити локальну їжу
і не потрібно шукати ресурси дуже далеко.
Вони є поряд з нами.
Наразі є лише певні залишки.
Але тут був базилік, який ще нещодавно
був дуже духмяний і запашний.
І навіть цей базилік використовували в нас на Промбарі.
Вони його використовували як декор на коктейлі.
«Лабораторія Р», яка тут діє від початку, займається
питанням сортування, переробки сміття.
За принципом циркулярної економіки аналізують,
як побудувати всі процеси роботи з продуктами так,
щоб вони усвідомлено працювали
від початку використання до переробки
на всьому «Промприладі» і цілому місті.
Моє життя перепліталося з різними процесами.
Я був дотичний до шведської компанії Ikea.
Це Інґвар Кампрад надихав мене
своїм підходом до заощадливості.
Був у різних країнах, подорожував.
Так я зрозумів, що, окрім того,
що потрібно рухатися, діяти,
потрібно згадувати й про те,
як ми залишимо після себе планету, на якій ми живемо.
Почали проєкт з того, що рекламні банери
не переробляють в Україні, у світі теж.
Ми думали, що з них можна зробити.
Подій на «Промприладі» багато.
Ми вирішили їх перешивати на мерч.
І продавали й роздавали учасникам.
Коли йдеш з такою сумкою, одразу зрозуміло,
чому вона зроблена і звідки вона,
згадуєш ті події, які відбувалися,
а також цінність того, що це могло бути колись сміттям.
Сергій Камінський — це один з найвідоміших
і найперспективніших науковців країни.
Разом з командою вони переїхали до нас з Києва.
Уже два роки живуть в Івано-Франківську разом зі сім'єю.
Вони збудували тут тестову лабораторію
«R&D центр» з тестування екобатарей нового покоління.
Власне зараз вони наближаються
до промислового виробництва свого продукту.
Без науки, без технологій взагалі розмовляти
про якийсь розвиток – це пусті слова.
Це насправді не так просто знайти людей,
які з тобою на одній хвилі.
Коли я відчуваю, що людина на тій же хвилі, що й я,
то, по-перше, дуже здивований,
що є ще такі люди, як я.
По-друге, коли люди не просто мріють,
а беруть і роблять,
втілюють ці мрії в життя.
Власне тому і відчув, що мені потрібно сюди їхати.
І поїхав.
У нас 70 відсотків проєкту належить співінвесторам,
а 30 відсотків належить внутрішньому благодійному фонду,
який залучає грантові кошти, ресурси на створення
прямої соціяльної інфраструктури в межах цього проєкту.
І з цього боку ми вже залучили
860 тисяч доларів грантових ресурсів.
І завдяки цьому створюємо різні мистецькі проєкти,
освітні, наукові тощо.
Перший проєкт називається Cumbima.
Це такий спільний аудіовізуальний досвід
площі в місті Тірана. Це столиця Албанії.
Я говорю: «Скажи мені в якому стані в тебе
знаходяться освіта, мистецтво й економіка,
а я скажу, в якому місті,
в якій країні ти живеш».
Тому що освіта, мистецтво — критично важливі
компоненти для розвитку критичного мислення,
але дуже важливо підкріпити
економічним потенціялом реалізації себе.
Бо якщо ми прокачаємо освіту і мистецтво
та не підкріпимо економікою,
то ми просто будемо донорами талантів
для інших країн, міст.
Можна сказати, що зараз якраз Мetalab
є відповідальною за напрямок урбаністики в проєкті.
Ми займаємося і розвитком міста, і регіону.
Намагаємось проєктувати вплив,
який мав би мати «Промприлад» на місто і регіон,
і взагалі взаємодію на дуже різних масштабах
цього об'єкту з навколишнім світом.
Управління інвестиційної політики Івано-Франківська,
яке переїхало сюди на завод, —
це перший прецендент в Україні,
коли в єдиному просторі діють разом бізнес,
представники органів місцевого самоврядування,
громадянського суспільства.
Ігор Попадюк – керівник управління.
Ми активно співпрацюємо з владою у такий спосіб,
безпосередньо тут, на «Промприладі».
До нас приїжджали два американці з фонду
конкурентноспроможності й підтримки економіки.
Я їх повозив по Франківську, показав їм виробництва.
І потім вони вже розробили програми і почали давати
великі гранти на підтримку малого і середнього бізнесу.
Тут Наталка, яка з Framiore
і Shuflia каже: «Я подаюся туди».
І ми допомагали їй із цією заявкою.
Вона виграла три мільйони гривень
на створення швейного цеху на «Промприладі».
Якщо зараз, наприклад, за годину
в нас буде зустріч з Юрою і Ритою
по секторальній підтримці по освіті,
ми маємо тут розробляти і пишемо
величезну заявку на мільйони гривень на лабораторію,
де народжуватимуться інновації на «Промприладі».
Цікаво працювати з такими людьми.
Цікаво працювати з людьми, які мають
візію майбутнього на роки вперед, на десятиліття.
Щоразу, як я сюди повертаюся, кожного разу щось нове, ще інше.
Тому що тут є вже багато резидентів.
Тут є своє життя і динаміка.
Власне це і є краса цього проєкту,
що це живий організм, який саморозвивається.
Я думаю, що основний фундамент ми вже заклали.
Кожен, хто тут є, він теж співтворить.
Ще раз: це живий організм, який має природу
спільного творення на всіх етапах від початку.
І що далі, то більше.
Я прийшов в якийсь момент до формули,
що щасливий не той, в кого більше, а той, кому достатньо.
Те, що ми створюємо,
відноситься до нових категорій.
Мені цікаво перевинаходити і,
очевидно, що криза західного світу
зараз потребує пошуку нових моделей.
«Промприлад» є спробою давати такі відповіді
не лише для України, а й для глобального ринку.
Мені подобається намагатися
не бути в позиції «а давайте знайдемо рішення,
як нам, Україні, наздогнати світ».
Мені цікаво намагатися бути
частинкою того невеликого світу,
який займається дизайнуванням майбутнього
і вирішує не свої проблеми, а глобальні.